dès mardi les abonnés de Netflix seront
forcés d'inscrire dans leur profil une
localisation permanente d'où ils
pourront regarder les services de
diffusion en continu terminez donc le
partage de mot de passe d'un même compte
dans plusieurs foyers on en parle avec
Luc du pont qui est professeur au
Département de communication de
l'Université de taïwa bonsoir
bonsoir d'abord qu'est-ce que Netflix
exactement met en place aux petits
abonnés canadiens
donc techniquement c'est le modèle qui
fera froid de tout concrètement par
exemple vous aviez l'habitude d'avoir un
forfait familial les enfants ont quitté
depuis quelques mois quelques années ce
ne sera plus possible de partager le mot
de passe vous aviez l'habitude de
regarder Netflix au chalet et donc vous
aviez le numéro de passe que vous
transportez avec vous ce ne soit plus
possible de faire non plus et si vous
avez l'habitude de voyager avant par
exemple vous êtes basé à Montréal
soudainement vous avez un voyage
d'affaires à Québec au Saguenay Lac
Saint-Jean vous arrivez à l'hôtel vous
aviez l'habitude de regarder Netflix le
Netflix va vous dire il y a quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas et on va
vous envoyer à ce moment-là un mot de
passe bon pour un visionnement je le
précise oui d'accord faut se restreindre
pourquoi Netflix décide de faire ça
évidemment de ne pas plus de compétition
souvenons-nous que dans l'air un du
streaming Netflix c'était seul en fait
Netflix c'était tellement seul que
Disney distribuait ses contenus sur
Netflix ce qui est assez remarquable
quand on y pense aujourd'hui deux
évidemment donc alors c'est toute la
compétition c'est tous les coups liés
également à la production de contenu
l'an passé par exemple les géants du
streaming aux États-Unis investi plus de
100 milliards de dollars en production
de contenu alors il faut évidemment
rémunérer tout ça et trois ben pour la
première fois l'an dernier il s'est
passé quelque chose de tout à fait
immuité je me direz les gens de Netflix
soudainement on a constaté lors d'un
trimestre qu'on perdait des abonnés
évidemment c'est pas la fin du monde on
parle de autour de 250 millions
d'abonnés au moment où on se parle mais
c'était une première en tout cas
suffisamment importante pour que coup
sur coup on commence à réfléchir à la
possibilité donc de mettre fin au
partage des mots de passe et deux
initier le fameux forfait à des
publicités mais là est-ce qu'on va en
gagner où on va en perdre chez Netflix
des clients en annulant cette
possibilité de partager le mot de passe
c'est la grande question voici ce que je
pense qui risque de se passer je
rappelle qu'en 2022 on a commencé à
tester cette opération-là ou Guatemala
République Dominicaine entre autres donc
à la lumière de ce qui s'est passé il
faut conclure même si on n'a pas
d'information publique à ce statique que
ça s'est probablement relativement bien
pensé on est assis à j'appellerai
l'étape 2 ici donc le Canada pas les
États-Unis je le précise pas la
Grande-Bretagne non plus le Canada
Espagne évidemment le Portugal
voyez-vous donc on parle de marché test
ici a bien a bien des égards et donc à
la lumière de ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines ben visiblement Netflix
choisira d’étendre cette politique là
dans le sens d'une autre ou sinon on
modifiera certaines de ces de ces
politiques là au moment où on se parle
évidemment à l'air de la globalisation
les Canadiens sont au courant que les
Américains n'ont pas ce problème là
britanniques alors vous imaginez que sur
les médias sociaux ça se discute
énormément actuellement il y a beaucoup
de gens en particulier la plateforme a
quand même traversé une période
difficile en 2021 vous l'avez dit le
nombre d'abonnés a baissé pour la
première fois en disant est-ce que votre
connaissance c'est la même tendance pour
les autres services vous avez parlé de
dessiner plus il y a headbio il y a
crave il y a tout point TV est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire la même chose sur les
autres plateformes alors toutes les
autres plateformes au Mamour on se parle
observe le même type de phénomènes donc
le partage de mots de passe on sait ça
dans les faits Netflix le savait depuis
2016 et lorsqu'on posait la question à
Netflix à l'époque ce qu'on nous
répondait c'est pas négatif c'est la
preuve que le service est populaire
alors on voit bien évidemment qu'en
fonction des époques et des contextes
économiques la même question peut
générer des réponses différentes alors
oui Disney le signe toutes les autres
plateformes le savent également alors on
va entendre évidemment de voir ce qui va
se passer avec Netflix c'est
probablement les algorithmes les plus
avancés au monde on sait par exemple que
les différents les gens qui partagent et
qui regardent le plus de façon rafale
les contenus de Netflix sont les
Canadiens on sait exactement le nombre
de minutes que ça prend pour que vous
tombiez dans le panneau d'une série on
sait exactement le nombre de semaines ou
des épisodes que ça prend avant de vous
décidez de ça et de regarder une série
donc à cet égard là tous les yeux au
moment où on se parle sont tournés vers
Netflix et la grande question évidemment
c'est est-ce que nous aussi
éventuellement on pourra demander à ses
mêmes personnes là qui ont l'habitude de
partager leur mot de passe de nous
envoyer quelques dollars supplémentaires
mensuels Facebook par ailleurs a lancé
aujourd'hui un système d'abonnement
méthode pour authentifier le compte à
partir de 12 dollars par mois pour ceux
qui veulent l'authentifier est-ce que
c'est un signal que le modèle économique
de facebook va mal
c'est le Cigale en tout cas qu'on
traverse une séquence au pays du
numérique des géants du numérique et
s'inclus évidemment les crises dans ce
cas-ci un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus difficile parce que jusqu'à tout
récemment il faut connaître ça allait
plutôt bien dans le cas de Facebook on
se souviendra que bonhomme Malan on
connaissait une croissance des ventes
publicitaires de l'ordre de 30 à 40 %
certaines années soudainement tout ça au
ralenti on cherche de nouveaux revenus
on regarde le voisin Twitter qui l'a
fait avec un certain succès et
évidemment ça m'amène à penser que dans
un futur Patrice éloigné et snap et
technoc également
dans cette dans cette piscine là avec le
danger que ça sous-tend cependant je le
précise c'est que évidemment
officiellement on parle dans le cas de
Facebook de le faire pour des raisons de
sécurité on veut sécuriser les comptes
des gens les plus connus mais qui
connaissent donc la notoriété la plus
importante mais le petit danger vous
aurez compris c'est qu'il y a des
acteurs sur ces plateformes là donc des
gens qui produisent le contenu mais des
spectateurs également spectateur là à
l'occasion aime bien partager la photo
du dernier né la photo du dernier voyage
dans le sud également et donc dans un
futur pas très éloigné est-ce que ça
signifie concrètement c'est que la
portée de ces messages-là des
spectateurs donc de ceux qui refuseront
de payer la fameuse mensualité chaque
mois et bien ces gens-là finiront par ne
à peu près tout se voir donc pas de
réaction pas d'appréciation pas de
commentaire également il faut se
souvenir que la pierre d'assise des
médias sociaux c'est précisément ça
c'est que n'importe qui au fond
soudainement techniquement devient
immédiat à sa manière et c'est pour ça
que dans un temps je pense que la
réussite sera au rendez-vous mais je
pense que dans un tableau très
rapidement on verra que des limites à
cette politique très intéressante merci
pour cette analyse Luc Dupont ce soir
c'est un plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI